[Music]
face time spying news
oh no submitted by I'm watching you yeah
literally you literally are though what
right now an iPhone FaceTime bug is
freaking everyone out really no I know
what because you can't like I've hacked
into the computers you could hone
pewters see people when they're not
supposed to be seeing she was so excited
to tell the news yeah no I don't have no
news I was gonna start asking questions
already but then you were about to start
I thought you were gonna explain I was
gonna ask the question but then I saw
she's about to explain what's right it's
2019 we're actually letting her talk now
all right new us new year new us watch
his letter come watch his letter top
there's this new butt or this bug that
everyone's talking about this new recall
I was like there's a new bug it's not a
caterpillar discovered in FaceTime and
it's going all over social media because
everyone's like oh my god just disable
your FaceTime if you don't want to be
heard or seen look at that iPhone users
doesn't have that with don't have
[ __ ] friends okay that's funny cuz
you guys are all my friends
what do this happens anymore we do some
Oh what is it called
this call is called Android face face
this one is called it's called face face
Oh have you ever used it before it's
great I don't even use FaceTime in the
first place yes oh well were you exactly
face space in your face face I like
FaceTime alright so I'm gonna show you
guys this video of how this bug works we
try on each other here we go yeah you
have to add a person and
you can add yourself and then our
alliances know you'd hear it and then if
the person who you're calling presses
the power button till I shut it off
without answering it enables the video
so now they could hear and see you
that's [ __ ] crazy Wow
so how did that Best Buy employee have
find his hack I don't know they found it
but it just started spreading when once
it was discovered and so now like Apple
roaring ass conversations dude yeah
that's crazy
it's boring conversation did you hear
about the earpods now what people are
doing is they put it in a room oh no oh
yeah if you're like close range you can
hear the conversation that's happening
in there see I don't trust nobody dude
damn you mean you like the wireless one
you just leave it on the table that
white ones yeah one and then bring the
other one with you I think oh you know
what teenagers are gonna use that a lot
because they want to see if they're
friends of Thomas [ __ ] and all they're
talking about is [ __ ] they're arguing
over the next arc Marvel movie yeah
[Music]
what are you thinking oh no I was
thinking like if I if I was a teenager
now and then I had that I probably put
in a room with like teacher-parent
conference [ __ ] were they gonna see so I
can get ready to defend myself that's
how you know you're a good kid because I
was always in those conferences exactly
my teacher need to roast me in front of
my mom cuz roasting me every single day
wasn't enough goddamn reforms huge
parent-teacher conferences are supposed
to be in the room all right maybe I use
the wrong it's not good technical my pin
I think you couldn't wait for my parents
to come yeah cuz I I remember they would
sit there and they would talk [ __ ] about
you in front of the parent I do see some
kids though the good kids they're like
walking around looking at the art on the
wall and know your son's great you know
like he brings so much life to this
classroom yeah I've seen people like
that losers I thought they're supposed
to sit down and say like hey like I
thought I think if they don't need to
roast them Oh
teachers are roasting kids well yeah
they roast the [ __ ] out of me with an
example
don't be thing I change the story I told
her I changed the report card that's not
you're not efficient ratted me out
well she had to that's bad I don't know
but teachers are petty they do wait they
wait for the moment to [ __ ] with you
well I I know your [ __ ] parents gonna
beat you so much tell on you oh girl I
realize that a lot of the teachers back
then we're only like 24 25 years old
really minds was [ __ ] dinosaurs
really I had a teacher that was like 27
years old I'm friends with on Facebook
annales I had him I had I had one that
looks like a [ __ ] prehistoric [ __ ]
tortoise and she had those glasses that
had yeah this clinking bread she's so
old she [ __ ] pinched me and I was
like imma tell my parents and she's like
go ahead there are some weird like
instances like when you think back as a
kid that I kind of questioned what these
teachers were thinking cuz there was
this teacher named miss guilt consent
she told this a story about her getting
bullied in front of us yeah and then she
started bawling in front of the whole
class she told us what I'm saying right
and I'm in fourth grade at this time and
she's tell you this story or she flew
off a bike is she smashed all her teeth
then she had to get her a mouth like
wired shut she's telling the story
bawling in front of us how many cats
does she have huh probably 30 yeah but I
don't know why she told us that story I
just remember because they're cats
wouldn't kid they don't want to listen
to her name maybe that's what maybe we
were her therapy and I'm thinking about
that as an adult and it's like why did
you do that I think they're just venting
mmm I had a teacher uh she she got into
really bad class hit so the top of her
head missing already so she had long
hair so she would always tie her hair up
like this kind of like like like
Christina Aguilera like so she got do a
crisis she floated a head slide like a
b-boy head pick something like that but
she has like kind of deformity and so
she would know of course students are
like why do you want do your hair the
same way mrs. Kern which is all it's
because of this she took it down if she
showed you yeah it was just all balled
up here and you guys laughed at her a
little bit like 12 or 13 you know we
were trying that okay I think you missed
the point of our commotions we were
talking about how teachers are shitty
let's do this venting I know why she
don't just show any of that stuff with
us cuz you guys are part of me whatever
you dick no and then she also told us
she went to a Morocco or something and
she says always drink bottled water she
had diarrhea the whole time I'm like
what does that have to do with this
class
diarrhea I had a really young English
teacher um the one that I'm on like
right of friends with Facebook friends
on whatever now Chuck the idea out of
her head physically she went the [ __ ]
out of here it's like a Wii controller
type it and you was like quiet reading
time we just like it was like super
quiet is that for lunch also in the
Chico do you think I should call this
guy back
you you know this was senior year she
was like in her early twenties oh yeah
that's not bad she was cool it'd be
different if you're like a second grade
and then the hole sucked well we don't
know like tell us about him and then we
just like I'll give her why why are you
asking us for life or relationship
advice she's like you she's dating one
of the students Doug yeah easy [ __ ] dude
she's [ __ ] one of the football dudes
do but as like teachers too though if
you if you if you went to like a more
like I guess LAUSD the me right here
baby yeah you know the staff is not that
bright it's like that [ __ ] blind
leading the blind it's pretty [ __ ]
dumb and I remember we didn't have a
dare program we got a great program have
you heard of gret gangs resistance or
whatever huh but it was like green and
it said great we had sane that way yeah
yeah no we had great least I really
wanted the DARE program but then the
great program they got this former gang
member and then she would come and she
would like I don't know she would talk
about her life no she didn't but she had
a few tattoos on her hands and whatever
but I thought she was older you know she
was all sure she was already like
[ __ ] war-torn and [ __ ] but every
single time talking about her she looked
like she was about to [ __ ] croak
though from like yeah I bet you she was
only like 30 but she looked 50 so like
so every time she would talk about her
gang [ __ ] right she would be so into her
fights and like oh you know what and
then this this [ __ ] thread set and
this one we went and we [ __ ] did that
[ __ ] and all the kids will be like
really and by the end of it everyone's
all hyped up to fight so she tells this
whole story that she's like you know
what join a game is a good memory to
share yeah like this is your future she
was meant to like [ __ ] get keep keep
kids off of tags like but she made it so
cool yeah in the beginning she's like
you know you don't want to like you
don't want to [ __ ] live like this and
then like she would progressively start
cussing and getting like heated
and then we were across the street and
when I was up there and all the kids are
like oh you need to do a better
screening process cuz Edie told us a
story about when he went to Haiti to do
like the relief ship they had a couple
of former gang members show up and like
tell these kids about living a good life
or what it was kind of weird because I
don't know why you would do that in
Haiti when they're all [ __ ] torn up
from other disasters yeah but the only
because they don't really understand
English very well
and like the people in translating that
well all they were see were his tattoos
and they just wanted to get tattoos the
whole time these kids are like trying to
figure out how to get these gang tattoos
on them Oh didn't do what they were
supposed to do xa they show up in the
food line with maybe two local do their
faces shops on their faces shoot what do
you guys remember those like spy toys a
little spy do that yeah like you're
thinking oh yeah they have their like
glasses with their two little video
camera if you didn't go through a spy
phase as a kid something's wrong with
you movie Harriet the Spy oh my god
haven't have been so long holy [ __ ] and
there were spy toys too like
walkie-talkies and all you would hear
just buzz and [ __ ] then you hear
moment remember and that's like your
friend off you know like I could hear
better without this shitty nerve I know
my childhood that's cool they still have
them cuz he got out of Book Fair I'm
just spying on my grandparents talking
[ __ ] about me with that thing then I
realized I heard better when I just took
it out there just right next to your
face you sit - you holding their baby
what they're gonna say have you guys
ever been to a spy store I want to yeah
scary though it freaks me out because
I'm like oh my god these things can all
be hiding my Airbnb or something I wants
the thing that that like the buttons
like this and it's a camera
mm-hmm yeah but yeah just like one of
these things
you gotta
right and say it again safety you know
you're all the undercover cop do you
have drugs anyway so yeah Apple said
that they are going to fix this bug and
then force the UH
what a great conclusion
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]